all right let's continue oh [ __ ] wait a
minute too bright it's like [ __ ]
green now yeah we'll see
all I know is way too [ __ ] bright
before there we go
fine Robert no you find Robert okay okay
okay okay let me sit no I just kind of
quit mitt okay yeah there we go let's
say I don't know how the save thing
works Oh oh it is so much better okay
anything in here oh yeah key card
I guess wooden okay so yeah I did lose a
little bit for that kind of quit right
after the save any [ __ ] in here
yeah there ain't [ __ ] in here I thought
the key card is right there you
generally generated I don't know okay my
hack you [ __ ] see now it's
interesting I ain't [ __ ] in here we're
here ready we're here already
okay now let's go open this door
[Music]
anyone I thought there was like [ __ ]
clicking yeah who is that
[ __ ] is that door locked
[ __ ] okay wow it's amazing how much you
can actually see when there's freaking
light in this game anything in here
that's good yeah
the [ __ ] is that whoa
was it inappropriate with materials
I think stalking scary anyways um yeah
what this thing was
it features just to think backwards this
is backwards here two five three three
two five three three
heck yeah baby oh okay I'm for
registering my retina okay I guess
that's that
oh [ __ ] that is two can't be good
oh they turn out the light on me oh [ __ ]
I thought up impact again what is that
bro I can't see [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] flashlight thank God
holy Toledo it is way over there and
take funny once I open up the [ __ ]
camera then this [ __ ] works I'm insecure
I feel super you free safe oh great how
is that I'm coming for you [ __ ] you
want to scare me go ahead cuz I'm [ __ ]
just runnin through this baby I ain't
scared a [ __ ] unless it is the tax
bikers helping out what scares me some
taxes they're in scanners a hallway back
here
wait have it gone here before I don't
[ __ ] him over this place
what the [ __ ] sure sir really bad at
drinking can coffee with this game woah
the [ __ ] urinal just talk to me they
breathed on me
hey man hang it this way
where's the [ __ ] retinal scanner oh
this is a new area for me horsey
I can't horsing around okay I know this
isn't a mirror what is that
[ __ ] xylophone
why does this place seems so different
main building [ __ ] locked what okay
that means somewhere near the [ __ ]
key or something
where's that penis thing okay let's see
here
we're off with all these toys everywhere
like that there's definitely a new
challenge or something now I know a
thing as I know what it is like it's
gonna be something like touch it in this
order or me that yeah see if there's
like animals but I don't have the
[ __ ] one paper that tells me where it
is
okay paper paper any paper around here
any paper I just want a piece of paper I
know there's a note around here
somewhere
ya know you shouldn't have to hide it so
much oh here we go here go
okay patient complaints of one-sided
intense headache that radiates to teeth
cause nausea mm-hmm estimate changes
here we go he they video monitor to
watch him a cardboard box named Carl due
to the continuous demand we decided to
place a box miss Christian coral and the
cell the physical place the patients
should you respond well to measure
however did not contribute recovery okay
the [ __ ] is Carl
that's that Carl where is Carl coral is
a Walking Dead fans but now it's coral
that Fox that coral and I'm just looking
for papers at this point I think I think
I looked in here already I did I did
hello Carl okay so we've seen both of
these [ __ ] locked so I got to go back
here I gotta find the paper that tells
it all holy [ __ ] eat those that
actually scared me a little bit hmm
dad got me that got me I'll say that
my [ __ ] is coral
dete are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me that I
[ __ ] miss it
it was in here the whole time because
this is the only place have more than
looked now the porns gone so oh my god
insert your shift guard at your personal
password
okay so how do I like restore power
right in here just trying to race to our
power you know I don't know how much the
[ __ ] is the right now scattered if I
could go
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] open their retinas candy here
we're at the [ __ ] where the hell is the
retina scanner
I get [ __ ] you know [ __ ] [ __ ] hats
he's only like [ __ ] three rooms I
don't know how I'm [ __ ] lost
what the [ __ ]
let me see retinal scanner right Claire
I don't know what the hell like where
the [ __ ] is the box oh yeah
[ __ ] how I get you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me yep
nothing is so [ __ ] tiny would've
never found it oh my god okay looks like
we're back in business
and this guy can walk like two seconds
before getting tired so yeah you know I
custody yep new jumps guys gonna be here
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] Donny man luck
bring dolly his xylophone the [ __ ] is
dolly
his ila phone I think this al phone was
like over here but I don't know don't
[ __ ] dahlias
if I kick up yeah things on the side
there we go
whoa what the [ __ ] hey [ __ ] is Dolly
like a doll like here it is all here
oh okay there we go okay now what
let's say still angry hey [ __ ]
jump-scare I know it put the dice on my
horse alright [ __ ] the dust I think the
dice is close to here though I think
it's like right here
yeah where you go over see it was over
here [ __ ] scary it's so quiet someone
gonna jump up and scare my [ __ ] legs
second tired you know just tired I guess
I got to put the teddy bear and the
thing [ __ ] I'm going and do it yeah
can't touch it
[ __ ] scary
but we stare pebbles in the stroller so
I [ __ ] tried to do but you see it
went yeah I think mr. Rios over here you
know this guy breed level mr. cuddles is
that bad Mouse well uh Swisher pebbles
is like the [ __ ] horse eh yeah let's
talk is mr. pebbles
mr. pebbles quick [ __ ] [ __ ] around
close this door
got to get up and personal with mr.
cuddles Alice come one thing
your [ __ ] jokes Campbell right now if
I [ __ ] made to not work what do you
want me to do [ __ ] not triggered okay
now it has to work
[ __ ] mr. pebbles there's always one
you know there's always one troublemaker
oh my god ya little [ __ ]
I don't know what the hell that always
says it's one fighting skill [ __ ] I mean
now this guy right
oh he's [ __ ] gone [ __ ] ego [ __ ] did
he go there we go
there you go oh [ __ ] whoa remember this
case it happened in one of the episodes
of my favorite show Dianna loved it too
but had horrible nightmares after the
episode huh confession
don't know how many these are like
programmers
all right oh my god so scary so scary
guys I got it
yeah I got knocked right
I know this place that's vice now I
don't know it was a [ __ ] like closet
I was it alright can I get out here now
go ahead won't security door right here
they're all [ __ ] up still
they're all [ __ ] off I'm gonna go
back to somewhere I can get back to like
wherever virtually was this looks more
like it yeah now that got the eye
scanner here's the one
yeah yeah you draw it over here here we
go
a perfect thank you mm-hmm that justice
thing no one is looking for right here
interesting
the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
quite a stick on there show those
pictures
Adrian Adrian huh Carl
okay two down two down jump scares in
this one jump scares in this one chatter
Alison whoa you're working at the lever
x12 or a laboratory x12 or several
months first day work I don't know why
but everyone worked really weird never
saw the patient's you're brought in
again we'd forced you anyway I think you
should come with excuse to gain access
to the test rooms
get me an access card for x12
and so I need you to plus up that work
right Oh your favor had John sit down
next to me at lunch and you'll get one
whoa you're filmed with CCT
we're circling we're conducting patients
press conference
holy [ __ ] that scared me holy [ __ ]
hey we jump yeah great [ __ ] pt
captioners still going huh
[ __ ] darkest [ __ ]
like a sample with us oh my goodness
really sad
[Music]
really sad
oh that's on now and a roll minute Dean
there we go
sass working
not get scary
and create the myself I'm bored
we're on [ __ ] [ __ ] my decks are three
suck this isn't bad this is bad
the [ __ ] is this
a try to but I cannot grab [ __ ] lost
now on the ceiling for one of these
seasons the [ __ ] key is that hey ya
little [ __ ] thank ya thank ya that [ __ ]
[ __ ] darkness now they got me Oh
sad
so I need to you
shut it off
[ __ ] it's closed
[ __ ]
guess again crazy in here
- they don't mean anything they're just
in combinations
how sunny 83 that
it's [ __ ] heart insides good that's
how it has to be the second one
so almost 9:00
so annoyed okay holy [ __ ] am i close
I'm [ __ ] with the second one now
okay we're just learning to get some
check because they don't make any sense
there's no like code or anything okay
[ __ ] it
okay yes I satisfied it
you're blocked
what now it's scary actually Jesus I
didn't know I got music
well okay guess what on this here Wow
[Music]